مشاهدينا ينضم الينا وزير الخارجيه
التركيه مولود شاوولو اهلا بك معنا سعاده
الوزير تعازينا الحاره في ضحايا تركيا في
هذا الزلزال وربما السؤال الملح الان عن
الحاجه التي
تتطلبها هذه المرحله دعوتم المجتمع الدولي
للتدخل والمساعده ما مدى رضاكم عن الدعم
الدولي لتركيا في هذه الازمه حتى الان
الامر شكرا جزيلا
لكلماتكم كلمات التضامن التي عبرتم عنها
مع انا وثانيا نحن ممتنون لكل الناس الدول
والمنظمات الدوليه ممتنون للدعم الذي
قدموه
للشعب التركي
ولضحايا هذا الزلزال الذي ضربه تركيا نريد
كذلك ان نشكر تضامن الشعوب المختلفه الدول
المختلفه المنظمات الدوليه المختلفه
بالطبع بامكاننا فقط ان نشكرهم لان كثيرين
من هؤلاء
يواصلون دعمهم لنا وهناك شحنات تاتين من
دول متعدده دول صديقه وكذلك دول حليفه لنا
الوزير خارجيه تركيا
ومواطن تركي بامكاني فقط ان اشكر الناس
ونحن سعداء تماما تجاه هذا التضامن وتجاه
هذا الدعم الذي قدم لتركيا
[موسيقى]
هل يمكن ان تعطينا التصور لحجم هذا الدعم
والدول التي شاركت فيه وما هو المتوقع من
قبلكم ما الذي تحتاجونه اكثر في هذا
الاطار
[موسيقى]
شكرا شكرا جزيلا
شكرا لهذا السؤال
سوف حتى الان
97 دوله و16 منظمه دوليه قدمت مساعداتها
هناك واحد وستون دوله موجوده على الارض
مما يعني اكثر من 7000 من العاملين
الموجودين على الارض ثمانيه عشر دوله كذلك
تعد المساعدات الانسانيه بعض هذه
المساعدات هي في طريقها الى تركيا والبعض
الاخر يرسلون بفرق بحث وانقاذ اضافيه لتصل
الى تركيا في ال 24 ساعه القادمه
سنحصل على اكثر من الفي من الطواقم البحث
والانقاذ سيصلنا الى تركيا
للمشاركه في عمليه البحث والانقاذ في هذه
المنطقه التي تاثرت بالزلزال سنواصل تحديث
احتياجاتنا سنحدث معلومات الدول
والمنظمات الدوليه المهتمه بتقديم الدعم
لتركيا وللشعب التركي في الوقت الحالي نحن
نحتاج الى
خيام مضاده
لاحوال الطقس التي بامكانها ان تتعامل مع
احوال الطقس وكذلك حاويات وكذلك بعض
المعدات مثل
البطانيات وكذلك بعض المعدات المتنقله في
الوقت الذي نحاول فيه اجلاء الاشخاص الذين
يريدون مو غادرت هذه المنطقه للذهاب الى
بلده انطاليا
لدينا عدد من التسيرات والتيسيرات التي
نقدمها لهم لكن لا يزال هناك الكثير من
الاشخاص الذين يودون البقاء في هذه
المنطقه ولان لديهم اسرهم هنا في هذه
المنطقه وهناك بعض الاشخاص الذين لا
يزالون تحت الانقاض وبالتالي هذا يتطلب
منا ان نقدم الخيام المناسبه لفصل الشتاء
وكل المعدات ذات الصله في هذه الاجواء
بطبيعه الحال لكم حديث يتعلق
[موسيقى]
بالحدود التركيه السوريه والمعابر هناك
والوضع لا يخفى عليكم في الداخل السوري
وكان هناك فتح الباب لمعبر باب الهوى ما
التطور في هذا الملف هل هناك فرصه لفتح
المزيد من المعابر
الخاص عندما يتعلق الامر بمنطقه شمال غرب
سوريا التي تاثرت بهذا الزلزال الكبير
والوضع يدعو الى الكثير من القلق نحن
كتركيه يسرنا الدعم الدولي ليصل الى الشعب
السوري لقد اشرتم الى واحده من هذه
المعابر وهي التي هي باب الهوى التي
تستخدم من قبل الامم المتحده لتقديم
المساعدات عبر الحدود هذه البوابه هي
مفتوحه معبر لكن لسوء الحظ الطرق المؤديه
الى هناك تضررت تحاول ان نحل هذه المشكله
وهناك 9 من
الشاحنات الامميه التي عبرت هذه المنطقه
وكذلك نقترح على المجتمع الدولي ليستخدموا
في منطقه كيلس هذه المساله هي ليست مساله
سياسيه هذه قضيه انسانيه وبالتالي نحن
نحتاج ان نواصل تيسير الدعم الدولي ليصل
الى الشعب السوري كذلك
في خصوص سوريا ايضا والمساعدات التي
تحتاجها وايضا الاحتياجات التي قد تستمر
لفتره طويله كما ذكر ذلك الرئيس التركي
قبل قليل من اليمن ان الحاجه قد تستمر
لفتره طويله لا رسالتكم للمجتمع الدولي
بهذا الخصوص
الكثير من الدول في العالم
لا تعترف بالنظام الحالي في سوريا للاسباب
المعروفه
لكن
هناك نداء دولي ليكون هناك مساعدات
انسانيه تقدم لسوريا هذه المساعده سيتم
تقديمها بشكل مباشر للشعب السوري وبالطبع
نحن كتريا نحن ممتنون
للمجتمع الدولي للدعم والمساعدات التي
قدمها لنا
وسنبذل قصار جهدنا
لتيسير الدعم الانساني للشعب السوري
وبالتالي لابد ان تقدم المساعدات كذلك
للشعب السوري لابد كذلك انه ييسر ليس فقط
وصول المساعده الانسانيه عبر العدود وانما
كذلك المساعدات الاخرى التي ربما قد تاتي
من دمشق المساله هي ليست مساله سياسيه
الوضع هو وضع انساني نواجهه جميعنا
بالحديث عن
الطول امد هذه الازمه الان باعتبار ان عدد
المحتاجين للمساعدات كبير عدد الذين
يخرجون من هذه المدن كبير ايضا
والاحتياجات تزيد
في هذا الخصوص هل تتوقعون مزيدا من الدعم
للدول الصديقه وايضا الدول التي وعدتكم من
قبل ان يستمر لاطول مده ممكنه طالما ان
الازمه قد تمتد بشكل اكبر فيما يتعلق
بالاحتياجات
من تركوا منازلهم بلا ماوى
شكرا جزيلا شكرا لهذا السؤال كذلك
13 مليون شخص في تركيا تاثروا بهذا
الزلزال الكبير
الكثير من المباني انهارت نتحدث عن سته
الاف من المباني ليس فقط بيوت صغيره وانما
كذلك مباني وشقق الامر سيستغرق وقتا من
اجل التعافي تركيزنا الان هو انقاذ الناس
البحث والانقاذ في هذه الاثناء كذلك نحتاج
ان نفي بالاحتياجات الاساسيه للناس على
الماده القصير كما اشرت نحتاج الى حاويات
وكذلك الى خيم من اجل تقديمها للناس لكن
على المدى البعيد تحتاج الى اعاده بناء كل
هذه المدن التي هي جزء من تركيا الكثير من
الزملاء يتصلون بي بعض الزملاء اتصلوا بي
ثلاث مرات وانا ممتن حقيقه لكل نظرائي
الذين اتصلوا بي وبشكل متكرر
سالوني عن ما يحتاج اليه الشعب التركي وعن
ما تحتاج اليه تركيا الاتحاد الاوروبي
كذلك قرر بان يقوم
باستضافه مؤتمر دولي للمانحين ونحن نشكرهم
على ذلك بالطبع الامر منوط
بالمجتمع الدولي
وسنواصل تحديث معلوماتهم بشان الاحتياجات
الموجوده لدى الضحايا
وما يحتاجون اليه على المدى القصير
المتوسط وكذلك المدى البعيد
بخصوص فرق الانقاذ التي توجهت كان ملاحظا
فيها النوعيه باعتبار ان الدول التي ارسلت
هذه الفرق كان لديها تجارب سابقه
بالنظر الى عدد المباني التي لم تمس حتى
الان باعتبار ان المساحه الجغرافيه لهذه
المباني المدمره كبيره هل تتوقعون ان
تستمر هذه الاعمال مع الزمن الذي طال خمسه
ايام حتى الان هل تتوقعون ان تستمر هذه
الفرق في عملها في عمليات الانقاذ تحديدا
والى متى
في بادئ الامر
ان اؤكد بان كل الفرق لديها خبره كبيره
الفرق المحليه ليس فقط الفرق الرسميه
وانما كذلك منظمات غير الحكوميه والفرق
الدوليه هي ليست لديها فقط خبره كبيره
وانما لديها تكريس للجهود كلها كرست نفسها
لابد ان تروا ان فعلت عواطف فرق
البحث والانقاذ عندما يقومون بانقاذ اي
شخص من تحت الانقاض لابد ان تروا رده
فعلهم اذا هنا يكرسون انفسهم ويعملون على
مدار الساعه دون ما نوم ولقد قاموا بانهاء
نشاطات البحث والانقاذ في بعض
المناطق وهم لا يزالون مواصله يقومون
بمواصله البحث والانقاذ في بعض المناطق
والولايات اخرى وهم سيقررون في نهايه
المطاف هم الخبراء هم الاشخاص الذين
يقدمون المشوره لنا بشان ما يجدر بنا ان
نقوم به وظيفتنا تقتضي ان ندعم كل هذه
الفرق الفرق المحليه والدوليه على حد سواء
لابد ان نتابع ونتبع المقترحات والتوصيات
التي يتقدمون بها
وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاو شغل شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذا الوقت الذي قضيتم معنا
على شاشه الجزيره رغم كل كل مشاغلك شكرا
جزيلا لك